I kind of get it from a business standpoint.
If they're filling the rooms.
I did a Gig in,
in Arizona once and they had a daytime gig booked from a youtube influencer.
They pack this place out at 11:00 AM with like 12 year old kids as fans.
Yes,
it was.
It was a Bert Kreischer day show.
He didn't take his whole shirt off.
It was a crop top or a halter.
Did Burt does those day shows?
He does.
We'll do radio and then we'll do a show at like noon for people that don't have
jobs.
It's like work,
uh,
call in sick to work or something as they call it.
Something like that.
Yeah.
Call in sick to work.
Yeah,
but this was God,
this was so funny.
That lady didn't know what to do.
Them just looking slim.
Yeah.
That is slim for Bert.
That's only like 19 months pregnant.
Yeah.
That's a protrusion and it's hard.
Eight year old in the valley.
He's got an eight year old inside of him.
He has to take his shirt.
He takes his shirt off in the or now,
every time I used to take his shirt off only in the main room was like whoa.
Or keep my shirt on.
No,
no,
we decided no more of that.
Does it come off all,
every show gets on stage.
He takes his shirt off.
When did you decide when that happens?
I wonder like is there a moment,
just write out how you do it pre,
pre Mike crap or grabs the mic.
Well his body is a source of pride.
He enjoys uh,
what the fruits of his Labor.
Yeah.
And his um,
appetite for a indulgence.
I Dunno if it's a body as much as it is a building,
it's a body.
People know what's his body.
They know he's a party animal.
Takes his shirt off and they go,
all right,
it's Burt.
Fuck yeah.
Woo.
He's,
he's fun.
It is a lot of fun.
It's a barnacle those written about that like talking about,
I was reading these,
this guy was like talking about how hilarious it was.
It's a party.
It definitely has.
I'm sorry he is an animal and sometimes you know,
I mean there's the opposite where people would just kind of quiet onstage,
fun on.
I'm sure laugh just by taking off my shirt.
I think I'd go for it.
Why not start off with it?
But now the problem is I think Bert owns it,
which is weird.
You know,
like he's like,
you think he should have some like a little bit of a feeling about it?
No,
like he owns it.
Like,
uh,
if I wanted to go up and take your shirt off,
people go,
what are you copying?
Hurt.
That's a good point.
He's the only comic disrobing every time.
But there's some weird ones like that Bobby,
Bobby Lee takes his pants off.
I mean,
I've,
I've seen that that weeny weeny a few times winking at me from the green rooms
of the comedies.
You should probably not tell people that first stop doing it.
People probably get mad now.
He can't,
he can't not do it.
They're like,
take off the shirt.
It was a jump on him on stage.
Tackle them.
Yeah.
But I mean there's,
there's a couple of dudes who go close clove lists.
You took off their pants and their shirts,
but the,
but it's weird that that's Burt's thing.
That is weird.
You're right though.
If anybody else were to do it,
they would know that that was a,
a Bert situation.
There was another one like that though.
We were just talking about the other night at the comedy store.
Like how does it,
someone like took over like a thing?
Yeah.
Oh,
stand up comedian.
I think so.
It does not,
I'm not gonna remember.
Remember.
I want to know what it is.
Well,
there's like a,
there's a comic in New York or d snaps.
Got like a snap every time.
That's it.
You know what Frazier Smith,
I love watching Frazier Smith when he was like,
come on people.
These are jokes and he likes maps.
It's like a,
it's like a timekeeper.
I like that.
Yeah.
It keeps you in rhythm.
It's musical up there sometimes if it's going,
if it goes well.
It's weird how people can become like a thing.
Like this is the guy who talks about food.
I know.
I was thinking about that.
Like how,
what,
what comes first in that scenario?
Does it naturally evolve or does it happen once and then the person builds
around it because it's a crutch.
Um,
there's a,
there's a fine line between the art and the marketing.
Exactly.
In who you know,
do your thing.
Like it's a short life.
Why not find that little niche that works for you and fucking make that money
and have fun and bring some joy to people who gives a fuck?
I have a problem where people would talk shit about people going after what
they're doing and finding a little trick to it.
Who cares isn't what everybody's doing to get tricked.
God.
That's true.
Fucking tricky.
I believed that shit.